my question is how can i its per client
how can she reversed her condition which
is diet Kinesis okay diet Kinesis okay
does that what does it mean how does it
matter so Tara did somebody told us she
had Tara Tara dies Dionysius I don't
know what that is
never heard of it it's in your book yeah
well guess what page 800 well then tell
me what it is if you're looking at it
tell me what it is dad Kinesis Kinesis
has to do an energy it doesn't matter I
don't have the book in front of me okay
don't tell me the page number tell me
what it means or facial muscles
okay Spanish and facial muscles Oh keys
on the increase of a side effect of
heavy tranquilizers okay okay
spasms of facial muscles well I had
those when I was a kid and it was called
Tourette syndrome okay and of course I
was able to get rid of it in just a
couple of days I'd taken the 90s sense
of nutrients how old is this female and
how much does she weigh well I can't
tell you you got to tell me how old are
you
no and how much do you weigh 120 pounds
when she's 83 okay does she have any
other issues diabetes how about pressure
arthritis do you have any other issues
diabetes high blood pressure arthritis
she has arthritis
okay well this spasm of the facial
muscles can be associated with that it
could be as a result of osteoporosis of
the skull and what what Charmaine is 83
years old I'd suspect you know this gal
here 120 pounds what would you give her
to help her with these problems ask you
process of the skull well for those
issues I would give her one
phone and join pack and some vitamin d3
ok great place to start you're exactly
right what else had something else one
more thing she could MS Oh the MSM yeah
there you go
yeah one healthy one healthy bone and
joint pack wouldn't hurt to get another
bottle of Asti oh so you can take two of
those bounces a day one a breakfast or
dinner half of everything else twice a
day fifteen gluco gel a day five at
breakfast five at lunch five at dinner
if she prefers the liquid she could get
two quarts of the liquid glucan gel take
an ounce twice a day you're exactly
right an 8-year old gal in Massachusetts
particularly during the winter time she
needs vitamin d3 two bottles a month of
that one three of those capsules twice a
day or two three times a day is six a
day however she does it and then MSM I'd
ever take two of those tablets twice or
three times a day to be two bottles a
month of the MSM and all this is to
support a healthy maintenance repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
matrix bonuses elf and this can be
related to everything from Bell's palsy
trigeminal neuralgia Tourette's syndrome
all that kind of stuff and so when it
comes to muscle spasms of the face I
again would get rid of all the bad foods
fried foods processed meats oils and
glutens and get on the supplement
program and then called some two weeks
in four weeks in six weeks the odds are
she's going to show some improvement and
let's see where we go from there but you
got to get her started someplace and
that's a good place to start